C'est moi. Mon nom est Ben Saunders.
Je suis spécialisé dans le remorquage d'objets lourds
dans des endroits glaciaux.
Le 11 mai de l'année dernière,
j'ai atteint seul le Pôle Nord géographique.
J'étais le seul être humain présent dans une region
d'une fois et demie la taille de l'Amérique.
14 millions de kilomètres carrés.
Plus de 2000 personnes ont gravi le Mont Everest.
12 personnes ont marché sur la lune.
Avec moi, seules 4 personnes
ont skié en solo jusqu'au Pôle Nord.
Et je crois que la raison --
(Applaudissements)
-- merci-- Je crois que la raison c'est -- c'est --
enfin, c'est comme Chris l'a dit, qu'on est cinglés.
C'est une aventure qui est juste à la limite
des possibilités humaines.
J'ai skié l'équivalent de 31 marathons
aller-retour. 1300 kilomètres en 10 semaines.
Et je tirais toute la nourriture dont j'avais besoin,
les réserves, l'équipement, le sac de couchage,
un caleçon de rechange -- tout ce dont j'avais besoin pour 3 mois.
(Rires)
Ce qu'on va essayer de faire aujourd'hui, avec les 16 minutes qu'il me reste,
c'est de répondre à trois questions. La première est : Pourquoi?
La seconde est :
Comment fait-on ses besoins par moins 40 ?
"Ben, j'ai lu quelque part qu'à moins 40
la peau nue gèle en moins d'une minute, donc comment fais-tu tes besoins ?"
Je répondrai à cela tout à l'heure.
La troisième : Comment faire mieux ? Que fait-on après ?
Tout a commencé en 2001.
Ma première expédition était avec un certain Pen Hadow-- un garçon extrêmement expérimenté.
C'était mon apprentissage polaire.
On essayait de skier depuis ce groupe d'îles ici,
Severnaya Zemlya, jusqu'au Pôle Nord.
Et ce qui me fascine à propos du Pôle Nord géographique,
c'est qu'il est en plein milieu de l'océan.
Il n'y a pas de meilleures cartes que ça,
et pour l'atteindre on doit littéralement skier
sur une croûte de glace,
la surface gelée de l'Océan Arctique.
J'avais parlé à tous les experts.
Lu des tas de livres, étudié les cartes et les données.
Mais j'ai réalisé le matin du premier jour
que je n'avais aucune idée
dans quoi je m'étais embarqué.
J'avais 23 ans et personne d'aussi jeune
n'avait tenté une aventure pareille.
Assez rapidement, à peu près tout
ce qui aurait pu mal tourner, tourna mal.
Un ours polaire nous a attaqué le deuxième jour.
J'ai attrapé une engelure au gros orteil gauche.
On était presque à court de nourriture. On avait faim, on perdait beaucoup de poids.
La météo était imprévisible, la glace était très mauvaise.
On avait
un système de communication archaïque.
Le téléphone satellite était trop cher, on avait donc une radio HF.
Vous voyez les deux bâtons dépassant du toit de la tente.
Il y a un câble enroulé.
C'était notre antenne.
On a eu moins de deux heures
de communication avec le monde extérieur en deux mois.
Finalement, on a manqué de temps.
On avait skié 650 kilomètres. Encore 300 à parcourir
pour arriver au Pôle, mais on n'avait plus le temps.
L'été était trop avancé, la glace commençait à fondre.
On a parlé aux hélicoptères russes sur la radio
ils nous ont dit : "Vous n'avez plus le temps.
On doit venir vous chercher".
Et j'ai senti que j'avais échoué totalement.
Que j'étais un raté.
Le seul but, le seul rêve que j'avais eu
pour autant que je m'en souvenais -- Je l'avais raté de beaucoup.
En skiant pendant ce premier voyage, j'avais deux
images fantasmées que je me repassais dans la tête
quand ça devenait dur d'avancer. Ça me gardait motivé.
La première c'était mon arrivée au Pôle.
Je me voyais très bien,
filmé depuis un hélicoptère sur un fond de music rock
brandissant un bâton de ski avec l'Union Jack au vent.
Je me voyais planter le drapeau, vous voyez.
Un instant de gloire, la musique montant en crescendo.
La deuxième image que j'avais imaginée
était mon retour à l'aéroport d'Heathrow.
Et là encore je voyais très bien
les flash des caméras qui crépitent,
les paparazzi, les chasseurs d'autographes,
les éditeurs venant me proposer des contrats.
Bien sûr, rien de tout cela n'est arrivé.
Nous n'avons pas atteint le Pôle, et on n' avait pas d'argent
pour faire notre pub, donc personne
n'a entendu parler de cette expédition.
Je suis arrivé à l'aéroport. Ma mère était là, mon frère,
mon grand père, avec un petit drapeau.
(Rires)
Et c'est tout. Je suis retourné vivre avec ma mère.
J'étais épuisé physiquement,
et une vraie épave mentalement, je me voyais en raté.
J'étais endetté jusqu'au cou
allongé sur le canapé de ma mère
tous les jours, je regardais la télé.
Mon frère m'a envoyé un SMS, c'est
une citation des Simpson. Ça dit :
"Tu as donné le maximum et échoué lamentablement
La morale est : N'essaye même pas"
(Rires)
Trois ans après je me suis enfin levé du canapé.
Et j'ai préparé une nouvelle expédition.
Je voulais faire la traversée, seul cette fois
en partant de Russie là haut
en passant par le Pôle Nord, le virage au milieu.
jusqu'au Canada.
Personne n'a fait une traversée complète de l'Océan Arctique en solo.
Deux Norvégiens l'ont fait en 2000. Personne en solo.
Le très célèbre alpiniste italien
Reinhold Messner, a essayé en 1995,
et a été secouru après une semaine.
Il décrivit cette expédition comme 10 fois
plus dangereuse que l'Everest.
Pour une raison ou une autre, c'est ce que je voulais faire,
mais je savais que pour rester en vie,
sans parler de réussir la traversée,
je devais adopter une approche radicale.
Ça incluait tout: du perfectionnement de
ma brosse à dent rabotée ultra-légère,
au travail réalisé avec les meilleurs nutritionnistes
pour développer une stratégie
nutritionnelle révolutionnaire à partir de zéro :
6 000 calories par jour.
L'expédition a commencé en février l'année dernière.
Grosse équipe technique. Des caméramen
des logisticiens
ma petite copine, un photographe.
En toute logique on a pris l'avion pour Moscou.
Puis vers Krasnoyarsk en Sibérie,
sur une compagnie russe : KrasAir,
ça s'épelle K-R-A-S.
Ensuite, on avait affrété un vieil avion russe
pour nous emmener à Khatanga,
le dernier lieu civilisé.
Notre cameraman, qui est assez nerveux en avion
a demandé au pilote, avant de monter, combien de temps le vol durerait,
le pilote -- un Russe -- impassible, a répondu
"six heures -- si on survit".
(Rires)
On est arrivé à Khatanga.
La blague dit que Khatanga n'est pas le bout du monde
mais qu'on peut le voir de là-bas.
(Rires)
On devait y passer une seule nuit. On est restés 10 jours.
Il y avait une sorte de conflit alcoolisé entre
les pilotes et les propriétaires de l'hélicoptère,
donc, on était bloqués. On ne pouvait pas bouger.
Finalement, le matin du onzième jour, on a pu
charger les deux hélicoptères volant en tandem
et me déposer sur la banquise.
On a eu 45 minutes effrénées de tournage,
et de photo, quand l'hélicoptère était là.
J'ai fait une interview sur le téléphone satellite,
et puis tout le monde est remonté dans l'hélico,
wham, la porte s'est fermée, et j'étais seul.
Je ne sais pas si un jour des mots pourront décrire ce moment.
Tout ce que je voulais c'était me ruer sur la porte,
frapper à la porte et dire, "Écoutez les gars,
il faut que je réfléchisse."
(Rires)
Pour noircir le tableau, vous voyez le point blanc,
en haut à droite; c'est la pleine lune.
On avait été bloqué en Russie et
la pleine lune amène les marées les plus importantes.
Quand vous êtes sur la surface glacée de l'océan,
hautes et basses marées veulent dire
que des choses intéressantes vont se passer -- la glace va bouger.
Je tirais deux traineaux comme vous le voyez;
Au total, 95 jours de nourriture et de pétrole.
180 kilos, presqu' exactement 400 pounds.
Quand la glace était plane ou à peu près
je pouvais tirer les deux.
Quand la glace n'était pas plane, c'était impossible.
Je devais en tirer un, puis revenir tirer l'autre.
J'escaladais littéralement les "Glaces de pression" --
la glace compressée par les courants océaniques,
le vent et les marées.
D'après la Nasa les conditions de la glace ont été les pires jamais enregistrées.
Et ça bougeait en permanence. La banquise dérivait.
J'ai skié avec le vent de face pendant
neuf des dix semaines que j'ai passées seul,
et je dérivais vers l'arrière la plupart du temps.
Mon record a été de moins 4 kilomètres.
Je me suis levé, j'ai démonté la tente, j'ai skié vers le Nord pendant 7 heures,
j'ai remonté la tente, et j'avais reculé de 4 kilomètres
par rapport à mon point de départ.
Je n'arrivais pas à suivre le rythme de la glace.
Nous sommes le jour 22.
Je suis allongé dans la tente, prêt à partir.
La météo est exécrable --
oh, j'ai dérivé en arrière sur 8 kilomètres
cette nuit.
Plus tard dans l'expédition le problème n'était plus la glace.
Mais l'absence de glace-les trous d'eau.
Je savais que ça arrivait. Que l'Arctique se réchauffait.
Je savais qu'il y aurait encore de l'eau. Et j'avais une arme secrète.
Ma petite dose de bio-mimétisme.
Les ours polaires en Arctique se déplacent en parfaite ligne droite.
S'ils arrivent à de l'eau, ils plongent, et traversent à la nage.
On a donc développé une combinaison sèche -- j'ai travaillé avec des Norvégiens --
inspirée d'une combinaison de survie --
que des pilotes d'hélico pourraient porter --
et que je pourrais enfiler. Je l'enfilais par dessus mes bottes et mes gants,
je la serrais autour de mon visage, très serré.
Ainsi je pouvais skier
sur de la glace très fine
et si je passais au travers, ce n'était pas la fin du monde.
Et, dans le pire des cas,
je pouvais l'enfiler et traverser à la nage
en trainant les traineaux après moi.
Une technologie assez radicale,
une approche radicale -- mais ça marchait parfaitement.
Une autre chose amusante de l'année dernière
ce sont les outils de communication.
En 1912, dans l'expédition Shackleton
il y avait un type qui s'appelait Thomas Orde-Lees.
Il a dit : "Les explorateurs de 2012,
s'il reste des choses à explorer,
transporteront sans doute des téléphones miniatures,
équipés de télescopes sans fil."
Orde-Lees s'est trompé d'environ 8 ans. Voici mon téléphone miniature.
Un téléphone satellite iridium.
Le télescope sans fil était un appareil photo que je mettais dans ma poche.
Chaque jour des 72 que j'ai passés seul sur la glace,
je bloggais depuis ma tente,
j'envoyais de petites notes,
des informations sur la distance parcourue
les conditions de la glace, la température
et une photo par jour.
Souvenez-vous en 2001
nous avions eu moins de deux heures de contact radio.
L'année dernière, je bloggais en direct d'une expédition
considérée comme 10 fois plus dangereuse que l'Everest.
Tout n'était pas High-Tech. Ici c'est de la navigation
dans ce qu'on appelle un "voile blanc".
Quand il y a beaucoup de brume, des nuages bas, la neige soulevée par le vent.
On ne voit pas grand chose. Vous pouvez voir un ruban
jaune attaché à mon bâton.
Je naviguais en utilisant la direction du vent.
C'était un mélange étrange de high tech et de low tech.
J'ai atteint le Pôle le 11 mai.
Ca m'a pris 68 jours pour l'atteindre depuis la Russie,
et il n'y a rien là-bas.
(Rires).
Il n'y a même pas de bâton sur le Pôle. Il n'y a rien,
parce que c'est de l'eau de mer. Ca dérive.
Plantez un drapeau ici, laissez-le, bientôt il dérivera vers le Canada ou le Groenland.
Je le savais, mais j'attendais quelque chose.
J'avais des sentiments mêlés: il faisait très chaud,
beaucoup d'eau autour, et
bien sûr, je jubilais d'y être arrivé seul
mais je commençais à réaliser
que mes chances de compléter la traversée vers le Canada,
qui était encore à 600 kilomètres,
étaient pour le moins ténues.
La seule preuve que j'ai d'y avoir été,
c'est une photo floue de mon GPS, le système de navigation.
Vous pouvez voir
il y a un 9 et une suite de zéro ici.
90 degrès Nord -- c'est pile sur le Pôle Nord.
J'ai pris une photo. Je me suis assis sur mon traineau. J'ai fait une vidéo.
Pris quelques photos. J'ai sorti mon téléphone satellite.
J'ai réchauffé la batterie sous mon aisselle.
J'ai appelé trois numéros. Ma mère.
Ma petite amie. Le PDG de mon sponsor.
Et j'ai eu trois... répondeurs.
(Rires)
Quatre-vingt dix.
C'est un sentiment spécial.
La planète entière
est en rotation
sous mes pieds.
Le monde entier est sous mes pieds.
J'ai finalement eu ma mère. Elle était au supermarché.
Elle a commencé à pleurer. M'a demandé de la rappeler.
(Rires).
J'ai skié pendant une semaine au-delà du Pôle.
Je voulais me rapprocher autant que possible du Canada,
avant que les conditions ne soient trop dangereuses.
Voici le dernier jour que j'ai passé sur la glace.
Quand j'ai parlé à mon équipe ils m'ont dit
"Ecoute Ben, les conditions sont trop dangereuses.
Il y a énormément d'eau juste au sud de ta position.
On voudrait venir te chercher.
Est-ce que tu pourrais trouver une piste ?"
Voilà la vue que j'avais ma tente,
quand j'ai eu cet appel du destin.
Je n'avais jamais construit de piste. Tony, le manager de l'expédition, m'a dit
"Ecoute Ben, tu dois trouver 500 mètres
de glace épaisse et plane."
La seule étendue de glace que j'ai pu trouver --
ça m'a pris 36 heures de ski pour trouver cette piste --
elle faisait exactement 473 mètres. Je mesurais avec mes skis.
Je ne l'ai pas dit à Tony. Je ne l'ai pas dit aux pilotes.
Je me disais que ca devait le faire.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
C'était juste. Un atterrissage spectaculaire --
L'avion est passé quatre fois,
et j'avais peur qu'il n'atterrisse pas du tout.
Je savais que le pilote s'appelait Troy. J'attendais de Troy
qu'il soit du plutôt du genre endurci.
Je pleurais à chaud de larme quand l'avion a atterri; c'était très intense.
Je me suis dit, il faut que tu te reprennes pour Troy.
T'es censé être l'explorateur coriace.
L'avion a roulé jusqu'à mon niveau.
La porte s'est ouverte. Le type a sauté. Grand comme ça. Il a dit "Salut, je suis Troy."
(Rires).
La co-pilote s'appelait Monica.
Elle portait un genre de pull tricoté à la main.
Les gens les moins virils que j'aie jamais rencontré, ils m'ont fait ma journée.
Troy a fumé une cigarette sur la banquise,
on a pris quelques photos.
Il a remonté l'échelle. Il a dit, "Juste- montez derrière".
Il a jeté sa cigarette en s'installant,
je suis monté derrière.
(Rires).
Il a fait des allers- retours sur la piste,
pour l'aplatir un peu, il a dit, "Bon, je vais --
je vais la tenter." Et il --
J'ai appris depuis que c'était la procédure normale, mais à ce moment là j'étais inquiet.
Il a mis sa main sur les gaz.
Vous pouvez voir que les contrôles pour le moteur sont en fait sur le toit du cockpit.
C'est cette petite barre là. Il a mis sa main sur les gaz.
Monica a posé doucement sa main sur la sienne.
Je me suis dit "Bon Dieu, on y est, c'est tout ou rien".
Ils l'ont poussé à fond. On a rebondi sur la piste. Et on a décollé tout juste.
Un des skis a raboté une arête de glace à la fin de la piste.
Je pouvais voir le cockpit, Troy qui bataillait avec les commandes,
il a sorti une main, l'a tendue vers l'arrière,
et a allumé un interrupteur sur le toit du cockpit,
c'était le signe "attachez vos ceintures" que vous voyez sur le mur.
(Rires).
C'est seulement depuis les airs que j'ai eu une vision d'ensemble.
Bien sûr quand on est sur la glace, on voit les obstacles un par un,
que ce soit une crête de pression ou de l'eau.
C'est probablement pour ça que je n'ai pas eu d'ennui avec la longueur de ma piste.
Ça commençait à se briser sérieusement.
Pourquoi ? Je ne suis pas un explorateur traditionnel.
Je ne skie pas avec des cartes détaillées;
tout le monde sait où est le Pôle Nord.
Au Pôle Sud il y a une grosse base scientifique. Une piste d'atterissage.
Un café, et une échoppe à touristes.
Pour moi, il s'agit d'explorer les limites humaines,
explorer les limites de la physiologie, de la psychologie
et de la technologie. C'est ça que m'excite.
C'est aussi une question de potentiel, sur un plan personnel.
C'est une chance pour moi d'explorer mes limites --
de reculer les limites de mon potentiel, voir jusqu'où elles vont.
Plus généralement, je suis étonné de voir comment les gens
traversent leur vie en effleurant à peine leur potentiel,
en faisant trois, quatre ou cinq pour cents
de ce dont ils sont capables. Donc
plus généralement, j'espère que ce voyage
a pu inspirer d'autres personnes
les amener à réfléchir à ce qu'ils font
de leur potentiel, et ce qu'ils veulent faire avec le peu de temps
dont ils disposent sur cette planète.
Je ne peux pas le résumer mieux que cela.
La question suivante est : Comment fait-on ses besoins par moins 40 ?
La réponse bien sûr est un secret industriel --
et la dernière question,
Que faire après ? Je serai rapide,
si j'ai une minute à la fin, je rentrerai dans les détails.
Que faire après ?
L'Antarctique.
C'est le continent le plus froid, le plus haut,
le plus venteux et le plus sec sur Terre.
Fin 1911, début 1912,
il y a eu une course au Pôle Sud.
Le coeur du continent antarctique.
Si on inclut la barrière de glace, vous voyez ici la barrière de Ross --
la grande surface ici -- la Barrière de Ross fait la taille de la France.
L'Antarctique, si on inclut les barrières de glaces,
fait deux fois la taille de l'Australie -- c'est très grand.
Et il y a cette course vers le Pôle entre Amundsen,
le Norvégien -- Amundsen était accompagné de chiens et de huskies --
et Scott, un britannique, Capitaine Scott.
Scott avait des genres de poneys et de tracteurs
et quelques chiens. Tous défaillirent.
et Scott et son équipe de quatre ont fini à pieds.
Ils ont atteint le Pôle fin janvier 1912
et y ont trouvé un drapeau Norvégien.
Il y avait une tente, une lettre au roi de Norvège.
Ils ont fait demi tour, se sont dirigés vers la côte,
et tous les cinq moururent.
Depuis, personne n'a jamais skié --
et c'était il y a 93 ans -- Ddepuis, personne n'a jamais skié
l'aller-retour des côtes de l'Antarctique au Pôle.
Toutes les expéditions vers le Pôle Sud que vous connaissez
sont soit reparties du Pôle par les airs ou ont utilisé des véhicules,
des chiens ou des cerfs volants ---
personne n'a fait le chemin retour. C'est ce que je veux réaliser.
Nous sommes deux.
C'est à peu près tout
Une dernière chose avant de vous parler des toilettes--
je possède -- je voulais le scanner mais j'ai oublié --
j'ai gardé un bulletin scolaire. J'avais 13 ans,
il est encadré au-dessus de mon bureau à la maison. Ca dit,
"Ben est dépourvu de tout l'élan nécessaire
pour accomplir quoi que ce soit de signifiant."
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Si j'ai appris une chose c'est celle-ci : personne d'autre que vous
ne peut décider de votre potentiel.
Vous êtes la seule personne qui décide jusqu'où aller et ce dont vous êtes capables.
Mesdames et Monsieur, c'était mon histoire. Merci beaucoup.
Merci beaucoup.